So I tried to
get Wayne Shorter
to express sounds
of the universe
through jazz, through
his saxophone.
OK.
So I prepped him for a cosmic
phenomenon to see how he--
can he roll with it.
- Uh-oh.
This is going to be deep.
Let's check it out.
I want to describe something
astrophysical to you,
and I'm wondering
if you can convert
that to a musical expression.
In the center of the sun,
energy is created by fusion,
and a photon of light is born.
This photon of light
careening back and forth
eventually escapes the sun.
That takes hundreds of thousands
of years for that photon
to get from the center of
the sun to its surface,
and it takes 8 minutes to
get from the sun to Earth.
Is there music in that?
Yeah.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
Can you feel the photon?
Trying to--
- Feel the photon.
Feel the-- oh, I like that.
Feeling-- that's an
album title right there,
feeling the photon.
The photon fears nothing.
OK.
[sustained note]
And if I move in any
direction other than that,
I think this one
thing incorporates all
of the movement and struggles
and everything like that
and all of the short-term goals
and stuff like that that other
people be looking for, and this
photon is wrapping around that
whole thing for millions
and millions of years,
and something else is wrapping
around that, and that's us.
OK, now we know
why people hate jazz.
What the hell was that?
Did you see your
face in that clip?
He was like, "pah,"
and you were like,
what the hell are you doing?
What are you doing
Wayne Shorter?